today i'm going to be speaking with kyle
reese mandel who's a senior university
lecturer
in the department of history at the new
jersey institute of technology
also author of the book neighborhood of
fear the suburban crisis in american
culture
1975 uh it's great to have you on today
kyle
thanks much for having me david so the
the suburbs as a concept
were maybe more relevant or discussed in
the 2020 presidential election than than
for a long time and
we heard from donald trump the suburban
women should love me and we heard all of
these different proclamations about
um rules and regulations regarding
the study of racial inequality in
suburbs rules and guidance that donald
trump wanted canceled but joe biden
i guess wanted to keep although i didn't
hear joe biden speak too much about it
one way or the other
can you talk a little bit about the
modern suburb
not from the architectural standpoint of
the subdivision but
as the sort of cultural thing of people
who sometimes
make a higher salary in a city but live
outside of it how long has that dynamic
existed in the united states so
it's pretty familiar in some ways i
think to a lot of people from
you know growing up with television
right that and this is exactly where my
cat will be interested in this
conversation
we love cats it's the second i started
talking
while i was sitting quietly she was just
enjoying the sun
so it's that it's that sort of um sitcom
suburb kind of idea the the nuclear
family the sort of strict gender roles
um everyone's happy everyone's safe uh
and so that cultural ideal emerges after
world war
ii with this you know the invention of
the modern suburbs so suburbs existed
before that but they were not
sort of necessarily the same kind of
formation so
and this is sort of average in american
history this idea of the single-family
house the nuclear
family and this arrangement of gender
roles um and sort of culture around
neighboring upward mobility home
ownership these are all new things
uh after world war ii the um
i mean correct me if i'm wrong but it
seems as though the culture of sort of
fear
in the suburbs about burglars kidnappers
home invasions people coming from the
city
targeting people in suburbs is there
something around the 70s
that made that start to grow as an idea
that people talked about
yeah so there's there's a few things
that happen so one is
to your previous question is that the
suburbs are kind of founded on this idea
of safety
and family and so people who move there
in this sort of later period by the
1970s right
they're expecting that kind of culture
that kind of environment that kind of
safety
uh and what they find by the mid 70s
it's actually more dangerous than they
imagined and so in the ways you were
just pointing out
sort of criminally morally
environmentally and to some degree the
fear is not necessarily external right
it's not that it is people from the city
coming to your suburb to rob you but
it's that people are lurking in your own
neighborhood who
are almost invisible right they're not
this kind of necessarily racialized
other
right but they are people who can move
freely and break into your home in the
middle of the day steal your child from
the mall
do these kinds of things so it's
actually a moment where they start to
feel this
this fear or threat internally rather
than externally right because the
earlier period as you probably know is
defined by sort of racial exclusion
right um and fears of racial integration
and those fears don't go away in that
you know after sort of 1975 but it
includes now these internal threats
within within cities the concept of
redlining
is maybe known to many in the audience
as a way to sort of uh
dictate racial lines between
neighborhoods
can you talk a little bit about from the
from the origins of suburbs
how were they racialized what were the
ways in which they were made
sort of race-based neighborhoods in a
sense
yeah so as you're probably aware uh
racial segregation
uh through space is not invented in you
know 1945 right that this exists
consistently throughout american history
right obviously during the period of
slavery but even after and jim crow etc
that
you know separating people by race and
space is not new
right what i really love is she manages
to go under the camera so i look insane
but so the policy of redlining comes out
of the 1930s and the federal housing
authority
during the great depression as a way to
help homeowners particularly farm owners
not just homeowners there weren't that
many homeowners
but one of the key ways in which they
evaluate investment right so the
government's giving out billions of
dollars
basically to rescue people is they say
we must consider the character of the
neighborhood including
who lives there by race and so this
bakes into the rules of housing
considerations of race and space and
value so when we have the suburban boom
of the 1940s and 50s
banks real estate agents homeowners are
all seeing property through the lens of
race that if
black people live in my neighborhood
it'll be worth less i won't be able to
sell my home
etc etc and and of course the inverse is
true that
black people then have extreme
difficulty buying homes because they
can't get loans
they won't be allowed into these
neighborhoods so this is sort of the
legacy of redlining
what um i mean it seems intuitively that
if you have people earning city salaries
and buying homes in the suburbs that
that is that is quite literally a
transfer of wealth from one sort of uh
structure to another but
there's probably more to that transfer
when it comes to
maybe political power or or sort of in
other words can you talk about some of
those other things
yeah so the outcomes of redlining and
suburbanization right so they're
happening at the same time
for the same reason so you end up with
urban crisis which is this moment of
a profound disinvestment in cities in
the 1960s that leads to the urban
rebellions you probably know about watts
or newark etc
so by the 70s the mass exodus of
generally speaking white people but
upwardly mobile white people
means that political power is following
them right representation in congress
particularly representation in state
legislatures
and frankly it's as we know now right
it's a lot easier to vote
as a suburban white person than an urban
person of color
so they are overrepresented in some
sense politically so
that movement of people really is
dragging with them this kind of base of
of voting power at sort of every level
of government
when uh when ronald reagan was president
it seems as though
that was great for the suburbs but i'd
be interested in in hearing a little bit
about was it
ideological and some of the stories that
reagan told or was there any actual
policy shift so both um
again the sort of backlash against the
welfare state ultimately right
yes cities more than suburbs so by the
time he becomes president
his policy of sort of um localism
privatization
um less government etc really empowers
people who are already powerful right
government already helps them they don't
need a lot more help versus say
people who need expanded welfare
benefits or snap or something else
so this retrenchment of government and
spending money on social welfare
you know health care etc allow
suburbanites to be empowered because
they already have all the advantages in
the system they're already structured to
benefit them
so they don't necessarily and in fact
they vote against those kinds of things
right the tax revolts of the 1970s are
exactly about that that
we don't want our tax money going into
these urban places we want to stay in
our neighborhoods we want our money back
right i i'm kind i want to talk a little
bit about
the the um power differences between
just like small towns versus suburbs but
maybe first it would be useful to talk a
little bit about
when we talk about a suburb i mean i
think the idea is
it's part of a metro area connected to a
city
it may have a downtown but oftentimes
it's not it's maybe more
residential and and maybe not at all
industrial like
these are just kind of intuitions but
what how are we really defining what a
suburb is versus what might just be a
small town
i mean you put your finger on what is a
lot of the historical work right he's
trying to figure out what are we
actually talking about here
we say suburban culture suburban life
suburban place and so
part of the argument making the book and
i think part of the way i teach this to
my students is
it is a construction right it is an idea
as much as anything else so it changes
over time what it means in 1955 is not
the same as 1975 or 1995. so to your
point
people imagine themselves as suburban
right and have um sort of enacting
certain values
conducting themselves a certain way
around law and order politics etc really
is what makes them suburban so
space matters and maybe relationship to
a city matters to some degree but it
doesn't
essentially define a suburb in a way
that i think is ultimately consistent or
allows us to say
this is absolutely a suburb this is
absolutely not so you could have a small
town and describe it as suburban without
it necessarily being
a suburb because of is it a combination
of
ideology economics yeah exactly
its culture its values and it is space
right that you know the suburban sprawl
of the 1970s the continuous sort of
development of land means that the
further and further you go out the less
relationship any place is really going
to have to an urban center so
you know the urban center is the center
of economic life the urban center as
sort of commuting or shopping right all
these things go away by the 1970s and
80s for most people
and especially if you move further
further out places like california or
pennsylvania places have a lot of
farmland that get developed
so what what can we say would be some of
the things that distinguish
a suburb from just like a relatively
wealthy smaller
small city or large town so i would
argue that i would i
would probably always ask the question
like when and where are we talking about
but i think
you know the consistent things
particularly in post-war america are
right
single-family housing focus on the
nuclear family or this idea of the
nuclear family around these particular
gender roles
and i think a culture of privatization
and local control that
the idea that i live here for these
reasons i control the space the school
board the mayor
and this is in some way an economic
investment in my future by owning a home
that those things are pretty consistent
as
what i would consider suburban values
but how they play out
it really again kind of depends on when
we're talking about this is part of the
argument the book is
by the late 70s people are starting to
define themselves in relationship to
their fears
that instead of saying this is what i
own and what i have and i feel safe i am
now afraid of
these number of things and i'm going to
react to them in certain ways that's
interesting so so
to put some examples to it a kind of a
wealthier college town in north carolina
or western massachusetts those those
might be suburban at least in their sort
of feel and idea
but maybe like a poor midwestern
small city or large town with tons of
public housing
would not be suburban under this general
idea
yeah and i mean again intentionally so
and this
sort of gets back to you to redlining
and ultimately urban renewal policies
after world war ii which is
suburbs many many places outside cities
past laws forbidding public housing
itself right
we will not even allow it to be built
here so uh and public housing really
stops being built by the 1970s we moved
to this sort of voucher system and other
things
but we're even having this conversation
today and back to your you know sort of
original point about donald trump
part of what he was saying about fair
housing open house and equal housing
right
is that he was trying to scare
suburbanites that they will build
apartment buildings
right to facilitate you know more dense
housing right yes
he's sort of saying undermines the idea
of your neighborhood um
the culture of the place yeah so let's
talk i mean when trump was talking about
the suburbs will be over under joe biden
and
all this it seemed to me that there was
a racialized
aspect of the idea of dangerous brown
people coming into a place that's
currently mostly white
is that a crazy way to interpret what he
was getting at
no and i think the thing about uh trump
is that he's stuck
in a particular vision of america
already right of the 50s 60s maybe even
the 1970s
that that was that moment right that
that was very truly
the suburbs were truly truly defined by
these very strict boundaries around race
and class
to the point where you have white
citizens councils you know policing
streets to keep out
black people from moving through not
just moving in but his vision
is old politically and sort of i think
just in any material sense
the suburb he's trying to defend is
already gone that suburban
suburban residents of voters largely
hold these progressive values even if
they don't enact them so they're never
going to come out and say
we don't want blank right they're going
to say we want to protect
this neighborhood the culture of this
place right the character of the
neighborhood
and that allows them to do all sorts of
things right not just keep out perhaps
people they see is lower class or
racialized to others but also
environmental things they see as
dangerous etc so
it gives them a lot of power to not play
the race card to think about it in
racial terms
and in fact i think they endorse in many
ways sort of progressive or
values around diversity so are
i guess the question would be are
suburbs
actually progressive or do they endorse
a language of progressivism
and they could really range politically
yeah this is the lesson of the 1980s is
that
and to some degree the reaction to civil
rights is that white people learn to use
the language of civil rights to make
claims
and this includes suburbanites and they
learn how to talk about race and class
without talking about race and class
they're the euphemisms of all these
things
the famous lee atwater quote the the
strategist for for ronald reagan
uh and george h.w bush that you know you
can't go around screaming the n-word
anymore you have to say you know
it's about school integration or
whatever it might be um
so to some degree i would say yes you're
right that what suburbanites care about
is an ideology of local power that what
serves that interest they will embrace
so they might vote for joe biden or
barack obama or even bill clinton right
but they don't necessarily want them to
enact those changes in their
neighborhood
yeah even though they still embrace that
idea of sort of
what i think we consider progressive
values one of the um
phrases or or claims that's been thrown
around a lot recently is that more and
more
uh people are going back to living in
cities
and and in urban environments the it
seems that there would be
some kind of seesaw effect suburb rural
and city and if more people are heading
to cities that would cause a change not
only in the cities but also in the
suburbs but
is is that the case what are the changes
we're seeing as a result of that
yeah i think the generation the second
or third generation of people raised in
suburbs returned to the city as quote
unquote fun city the place to go
that is gentrified that is safe some
scholars make the argument that this is
the suburbanization of the city itself
right
we sort of erase or marginalize the
people who've been in these
neighborhoods for many years you know
mostly um
latinx or black we make it safe we bring
these amenities these restaurants these
bars we sort of idealize this past this
sort of industrial past and our culture
but really it's about bringing in this
kind of investment right the kind of
tourism dollars consumer dollars
rental dollars that didn't exist there
before
as a reaction to the bland staleness of
the suburbs right like you know all the
things that people are saying in the
1980s particularly in hardcore punk of
you know this is just boring and
horrible and terrible it's about tv and
fast food
uh whereas this authentic urban
experience exists that i can access
big picture just to kind of uh wrap the
conversation
in thinking about the next you know 10
20 years
um what what do you see as sort of the
shifts
in terms of rural suburban and urban
that seem to be guided by the interests
of the people that are now becoming
homeowners will the shift to
urbanization continue or
do you expect it to change or reverse
well one is there are fewer homeowners
right so
probably i suspect you're around my age
or younger our generation are not going
to be the generation of homeowners in
the same way because we're not being
facilitated by the market or the
government to own homes um so we may
inherit homes many of us reckons where
you know some largely white people will
get our parents our grandparents homes
but home ownership i think as an idea
might have to be really reconfigured
because people are desiring some some um
intermediary between urban and suburban
experiences convenience
locality but also some sort of idea of
authenticity
but the pandemic also really throws us
into high relief right we've seen
i i think the exodus is maybe uh
overemphasized but people have moved out
of the city
seeing it as sort of the home of
pestilence right you know this kind of
almost
19th century idea of the city so it's
hard to say and anything about public
health or other things what that might
really mean
we may really see people kind of move
far out and go quote-unquote back to the
land
like a lot of people did in the 1970s
yeah that's uh that's a question which
i think as you point out we just don't
don't really know yet it's a new it's a
new question uh we've been speaking with
kyle rhys mandel who's a senior
university lecturer in history
at the new jersey institute of
technology the book is neighborhood of
fear the suburban crisis in american
culture
1975-2001 kyle so great having you on i
really appreciate it
thanks for me i really enjoyed it